TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER. A DUE TO
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
RESTRICTIONS WE ARE PRACTICING
SOCIAL DISTANCING IN HEARING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL
SO WERE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. NASSAR REQUIRED FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND IN THE WHICH WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM. THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM IS ROOM
ONE TWENTY FIVE. YOU CAN
TESTIFY IN PERSON OR USING OUR
TELEPHONE SERVICE. THE NUMBER
TO CALL IN TO GIVE TESTIMONY IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO.
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO. AND THIS
INFORMATION IS ON OUR WEBSITE.
YOU WILL BE PLACED IN QUEUE
UNTIL IT IS TIME FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE MUTE YOUR
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTIONS. SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE BLOOD ON THE
PHONE LINE AND LIMITED TO ONE
MINUTE PER PERSON AND WE WILL
STRICTLY ENFORCE THAT ONE
MINUTE PER PERSON. TO MANAGE
YOUR TIME AND KNOWING THINGS
TAKE LONGER THAN USUAL WE WILL
HAVE NO MORE THAN TWENTY
MINUTES OF DISCUSSION FOR EACH
BILL. IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE THREE
AND MY STAFF WILL TRY TO HELP.
BUT THEY WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
TAKE TESTIMONY FROM THAT NUMBER
THEY WILL JUST TRY TO HELP YOU
WITH THE OTHER NUMBER. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY FOR
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL. ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
WITHOUT WE WILL BEGIN OUR
HEARING- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FRIEDMAN HERE FONG
BERMAN. MATHIS DALY. DAVIES
GIPSON- KALRA. LEE MEDINA. THIS
AREA. WHEN. O'DONNELL WARD. THE
WARD THE- L. WHAT WICKS. DO
REAL CORE. IT WOULD GIVE A
QUORUM SO IF YOU ALL STAY PUT
WILL VOTE OTHERWISE WE CAN WILL
GO TO THE END FOR YOU- I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME ALL THE NEW MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME MYSELF AS THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE- I AM REALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO ALL OF YOU
TO DOING A LOT OF IMPORTANT
WORK THIS YEAR. MICHAEL IN THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO TRY TO MAKE OUR
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION POLICIES
AS PROGRESSIVE AN ASPIRATIONAL
AND AS CONCERNED WITH OUR HUGE
ISSUES LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE IN
MOBILITY OPTIONS AS THE REST OF
OUR STATE'S POLICIES- WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE OUR STREETS MUCH
SAFER. OF TRAFFIC FATALITIES
INCREASED BY 8% IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY DESPITE THERE BEING A
LOT LESS DRIVING BECAUSE OF
CODE NINETEEN WHICH SHOWS US
THAT THE ONLY THING THAT'S
REALLY PREVENTING A LOT OF LOSS
OF LIFE ON OUR ROADS IS TRAFFIC
CONGESTION AND THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE. THIS HAS BEEN THE
GREATEST A SINGLE YEAR INCREASE
IN TRAFFIC FATALITIES AND
INJURIES IN NINETY SIX YEARS SO
WE ARE GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION THE STATE AND NEED TO
RE CENTER OUR FOCUS ON KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE. I AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I'M VERY
COMMITTED TO TRYING TO DO THIS
YEAR IN THIS COMMITTEE. IN
ADDITION. TRANSPORTATION HAS
BEEN THE ONE AREA IN OUR STATE
WHERE WE'VE GONE THE WRONG
DIRECTION WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND REDUCING
EMISSIONS. WE KNOW THAT
TRANSPORTATION IS THE CAUSE OF
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF THE
STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
IN THAT AREA. WE ALSO REALLY DO
OUR CONSTITUENTS A DISSERVICE
BY NOT PROVIDING THEM ROBUST
MOBILITY OPTIONS THAT WILL
INCREASE PUBLIC HEALTH CLEAN UP
OUR AIR. AND BE A LOT MORE
ECONOMICALLY SUSTAINABLE FOR A
LOT OF OUR RESIDENTS
PARTICULARLY LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS. SIMPLY PUT WE NEED
TO INVEST A LOT MORE IN TRANSIT
IN MASS TRANSIT. THAT IS
CONVENIENT AND SAFE. AND FAST
AND MORE DESIRABLE FOR OUR
RESIDENTS NOT JUST FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT FOR BETTER LAND USE
POLICIES. FOR UGH EQUITY FOR
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT MAKE FOR
WORLD CLASS COMMUNITIES AND I
HOPE THAT YOU ALL WILL JOIN ME.
IN THOSE GOALS. TODAY WERE ALSO
GOING TO BE ADOPTING THE
COMMITTEE RULES IN THE
COMMITTEES HIGHWAY NAME POLICY
NOW HERE'S SOMETHING A LITTLE
BIT SHOCKING. AS OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN OVER SEVEN
HUNDRED SECTIONS OF FREEWAYS
HIGHWAYS AND STRUCTURES HAVE
BEEN NAMED HOWEVER. VERY FEW OF
THOSE NAMES ARE THOSE OF WOMEN.
IN FACT MY STUFF WENT THROUGH
THE NAMES AND FOUND THAT LESS
THAN OUT OF SEVEN HUNDRED NAMES.
LESS THAN FIFTY OF THEM ARE
NAMES OF WOMEN. SO IS CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE I PLAN TO PUT A
STOP TO THAT. AND WHAT I'M
GONNA DO IS I WILL TAKE FIVE
NAMES AND IF THEY'RE ALL MEN I
WILL NOT ALLOW FOR ANY MORE
RESOLUTIONS NAMING HIGHWAYS
WITH THIS COMMITTEE. UNTIL WE
HAVE FIVE WOMEN. OKAY THAT'S
WHAT I'M GONNA PLANT THAT'S MY
PLAN. I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
DEMAND. A LITTLE BIT OF
REPRESENTATION A LITTLE BIT OF
EQUITY. AND I THINK THAT WE
NEED TO BE PROMOTING AND
CELEBRATING THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF WOMEN AND THERE'S PLENTY OF
WOMEN OUT THERE THAT WE CAN
HONOR. IN THIS WAY. A MAY I
HAVE A MOTION FOR THE COMMITTEE
RULES AND HIGH WINNING POLICY I
HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
YEAH A MOTION AND A SECOND. DO
WE NED IT WE VOTE ON THE RULES
NOW. OKAY SO LET'S TAKE A VOTE
ROLE A ROLE- ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ON THE COMMITTEE ROLES.
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FONG.
FONG I BERMAN. BERMAN I MATHIS.
SINCE DALY. DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I GIPSON. GIPSON AYE
KALRA KALRA KILEY. B. I. MEDINA.
MEDINA I IN THIS AREA. WHEN.
TWENTY O'DONNELL DONAL I WARD.
WARD I WICKS WICKS I. THANK YOU
THE RULES ARE ADOPTED WE HAVE
THE FOLLOWING MEASURES ON
CONSENT AB THREE NINETY EIGHT
FONG AND CHOW AB. THREE TWO
THIRTY TWO GALLAGHER AND MATHIS
AB FOUR FIFTY NINE MATHIS AB
FIVE NINETY ONE VILLA PUTA AB
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE BENNETT IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
FILE. GOT A MOTION AND A SECOND
CAN WE HAVE THE ROLL CALL
PLEASE. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN I FONG.
FONG I BERMAN. BERMAN I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE DALY DALY AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I'D GIPSON- GIPSON AYE
KALRA. KALRA KILEY MAY I AM
MEDINA. MEDINA I IN THIS AREA.
WHEN DONALD. DAHLE AYE WARD.
WARD I WICKS WIXII. K. B.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS PASSED WE
HAVE THREE BILLS TO DISCUSS
TODAY AB THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG IS UP FIRST.
I WILL INVITE THE AUTHOR TO
OPEN ON THE BILL. RUBIO. GET A
MOTION AND A SECOND. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. I
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
ON AMENDMENTS WHICH WE GLADLY
ACCEPT THIS BILL APPLIES THE
PENALTIES FOR ILLEGAL STREET
RACING TO ALSO APPLY TO THE
EXHIBITION OF SPEED. WHICH IS
COMING OUT AS SIDE SHOWS OR
CARS ARE BURNING TIRES OUT
REVVING ENGINES AND PERFORMING
STUNTS TO SHOW OFF TO A CROWD
IN OUR STREETS. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW ENGAGING IN AN EXHIBITION
OF SPEED IS OFTEN COMBIND WITH
STREET RACING AND RECKLESS
DRIVING THAT PUTS SO MANY
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AT
RISK. THIS INTERACTIVITY HAS
SPIKED TREMENDOUSLY STATEWIDE
GETTING THE TRAGIC ACCIDENTS
AND SENSELESS DEATH OF ARGUE
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS THE
CHP HAS REPORTED A NEARLY 3100%
SURGE IN MOTOR VEHICLE
EXHIBITION SPEED CITATIONS. BUT
SADLY NOT ALL SPEED EXHIBITION
CASES AND WITH EDUCATION NEARLY
47% OF THESE CRASHES RESULT IN
INJURY 42% RESULT IN PROPERTY
DAMAGE. AND 11% RESULT IN DEATH.
THIS RECKLESS BEHAVIOR PLACES
STREETS OF HOW. CLAIMS INNOCENT
LIVES. INPUTS COMMUTERS
PEDESTRIANS AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AT RISK. I'M SURE WE ALL KNOW
OF THESE TRAGIC EVENTS IN OUR
OWN DISTRICTS AND
NEIGHBORHOODS. JUST LAST MONTH.
MY KERN COUNTY COMMITTEE LOST
ANOTHER INNOCENT RESIDENT AND A
STREET RACING CRASH. THAT ENDED
IN A FATAL HIT AND RUN AS THE
VICTIM WAS CROSSING THE STREET.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND KERN
COUNTIES MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK
DRIVING CHAPTER HAVE STRESSED
THAT THIS TROUBLING TREND IS
OFTEN CORRELATED WITH THINGS
LIKE DRUNK AND DRUG DRIVING.
AND OTHER ILLEGAL ACTIVITY. I
WANT TO CLEAR THE EIGHTY THREE
DOES NOT CREATE A NEW CRIME.
RATHER GIVES THE COURT THE
AUTHORITY TO TAKE ACTION ON
SPEED EXHIBITION INSIDE SHOWS.
PERFORMING RECKLESS BEATS
DUNSTAN STREET RACES ARE
EQUALLY DANGEROUS AND POSE AN
EQUAL RISK TO OUR ROADS. AND
COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER ONLY CAN
FOR THE LATTER CAN RESULT IN A
SUSPENDED LICENSE AB THREE
CLOSES THAT LOOPHOLE. AB THREE
SUPPORTER BY MOTHERS AGAINST
DRUNK DRIVING AND STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT GROUPS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ITEM.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS HEATHER
AND THE OUT. HEATHER AND THE-
DUBINSKY. WHO ARE SECOND
RESIDENTS AND THE PARENTS OF
AUSTIN. GOING TO A MAJOR MAJOR
PHYSICAL INJURIES DUE TO A
SPEED RALLY ACCIDENT LESS THAN
A YEAR AGO. I PASSED AROUND
SOME PHOTOS TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO THAT THEY CAN SEE THE PAIN
ENDURED BY THE FAMILY AS
HEATHER AND LEO PROVIDED
TESTIMONY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU WITH THAT WILL
TAKE THE FIRST WITNESS TWO
MINUTES PLEASE FOR THE WITNESS.
ONE MOMENT WE CAN'T HEAR YOU-
JUST GIVE US ONE MOMENT. WHY
DON'T YOU TRY AGAIN LET'S SEE
IF IT STARTS AT. NOPE SORRY I'M
A BIGGER PART IN PLEASE PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT. WE'RE WORKING IT
OUT ON OUR END JUST GIVE US A
MOMENT PLEASE AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. HELLO YES WE'VE GOT
YOU KNOW OKAY OKAY. HI MY
NAME'S HEATHER DUBINSKY IN THIS
IS MY HUSBAND LEO TWO MINUTES
GAME ON SEPTEMBER TWELFTH WE
GOT THE PHONE CALL THAT NO
PARENT SHOULD EVER GET. OUR SON
AS I KNEW I HAD BEEN. IN A CAR
WRECK THAT'S ALL I KNEW UNTIL I
GOT TO THE HOSPITAL. AND FOUND
OUT THAT MY SON WAS HIT BY A
CAR AND BASICALLY DRAGGED UNDER.
IT INJURIES WORK TREMENDOUS.
THE FIRST NIGHT THAT HE WAS IN
THE ER HE HAD HIS FIRST HE WAS
RUSHED INTO SURGERY HAD HIS
SPLEEN REMOVED AND TO HOPE THEY
FIXED ALL THE BLEEDING
INTERNALLY AND HE WAS MOVED
INTO THE ICY YOU. IN THE FIRST
WEEK HE HAD THREE SURGERIES-
THE FIRST ONE HE HAD HIS GOAL
PART OF A SCHOOL REMOVED
BECAUSE THE BRAIN SWELLING WAS
SO BAD. AND AFTER ABOUT TWO
DAYS LATER THREE DAYS LATER- HE
HAD PELVIS FIXED IT WAS
COMPLETELY BROKEN HE HAD
MULTIPLE- TISSUE AND SCRAPES
AND HOLES IN HIS BODY HE WAS
BASICALLY ON THE VERGE OF DEATH.
FOUR DAYS INTO- BEING THERE FOR
A FULL TWO MONTHS- THERE WAS
ACTUALLY A PER RALLY- OUTSIDE
PHYSICALLY DISTANCED WEARING
MASKS. AND THE PRAYERS WERE
PRAYED BY THREE HAVE OVER THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE FROM MY SIDE TO
HAVE FORGOT TO GIVE HIM ANOTHER
CHANCE. I'M FINDING IT OUT THE
NIGHT OF THE ACCIDENT THAT
ANOTHER BOY HAD DIED IN ELK
GROVE IT JUST MADE ME SO SAD-
BECAUSE I'VE I'VE BEEN GIVEN MY
SON'S BEEN GIVEN ANOTHER CHANCE
BUT- IN LEARNING ABOUT THIS IF
THERE BEEN SO MANY DEATHS OF
YOUNG KIDS. AND BEING TOLD BY
ONE OF GOOD NURSES WHEN MY SON
GOT OUT OF I SEE YOU'VE GOT
HE'S ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES THEY
NEVER SEE A RECOVERY LIKE THIS.
AND MY SON IS STILL RECOVERING
HE'S STILL- WORKING ON WALKING.
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
THAT HAVE OTHER FAMILIES NOT
HAVE TO GO WHAT OUR FAMILY WENT
THROUGH. THAT IS ALL. I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY AND I'M VERY VERY
SORRY FOR THE TRAUMA THAT YOUR
SON HAS GONE THROUGH AND YOU
HAVE GONE THROUGH WITH THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TO SHARE
WITH US TODAY DO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORT NO
THAT IS A GOOD IDEA WHO IT IS
OKAY. I DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YES
MA'AM CHARACTERS. KATHY SURE
FOR THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN PLEASE
PROCEED YOUR TWO MINUTES. GREAT
THANK YOU- GOOD AFTERNOON KATHY
SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA- LET ME START BY
SAYING HOW SORRY I AM FOR WHAT
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
THEIR SON HAVE HAD TO THE DOOR.
I THINK WE ALL SHARE THE GOAL
OF TRYING TO PREVENT INCIDENTS
LIKE THAT. UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT ANYTHING IN
THIS BILL WILL ACTUALLY HELP TO
PREVENT- OF THE OCCURRENCE OF
INCIDENTS LIKE WHAT HAPPENED TO
THOSE. ON I CURRENT LAW MAKES
THE EXHIBITION OF MISDEMEANOR.
BY A JAIL TERM OF UP TO NINETY
DAYS. A FINE OF UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS OR BOTH. WITH
HIGHER PENALTIES AVAILABLE WHEN
THE INCIDENT RESULT IN INJURY
OR PROPERTY DAMAGE. IN ADDITION
THE OFFICER MAKING THE ARREST
CAN SEIZE THE VEHICLE AND
IMPOUND FOR UP TO THIRTY DAYS.
ADDING LICENSE SUSPENSION TO
THE PENALTIES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THIS BEHAVIOR
WILL NOT STOP DRIVERS FROM
ENGAGING IN EXHIBITION THE-
INSTEAD FOR THOSE WHO ARE
SEEKING TO FIND THEIR WAY
TOWARD THE MORE LAW ABIDING
LIFE. WILL BECOME ONE MORE
HURDLE STANDING IN THE WAY OF
THEM BEING ABLE TO DRIVE
LEGALLY TO ATTEND SCHOOL TO
TAKE OTHERS IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD
TO THEIR WORKPLACES OR TO TAKE
THEMSELVES OR OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS MEDICAL POINT. YET
NOTHING IN AB THREE CALLS UPON
THE JUDGE TO TAKE ANY OF THESE
FACTORS INTO ACCOUNT WHEN
DETERMINING WHETHER TO SEND
SOMEONE LIKE. PILING ON NEW
PENALTIES DOES LITTLE TO REDUCE
CRIME BUT INSTEAD CAN HAVE A
RIPPLE EFFECT THAT HARMS THE
JOLT AND IT'S HIGHER UNITY. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR LOCAL.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTARY- IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL SEEING
NONE WILL OPEN GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE BRING THAT- BRING US
ANY COLORS WERE. PRESENT TO
SPEAK ON THE BILL. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
THREE IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ABOUT ROBINSON
WITH THE SPECIALTY EQUIPMENT
MARKET ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN
AS SHIMA BUT WE REPRESENT THE
AFTERMARKET AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY
TO HELP COTTON WITH FOURTEEN
HUNDRED BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA- AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
LONG TEACHERS. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RYAN
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CORY SOCIAL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
COLOR SHOULD BEING BRIEF NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEDICARE MEMBERS BRANDON
UP ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
FONG WRITING OF SORRY PLEASE IF
THERE WERE OTHER COLORS. I DO
HAVE ONE MORE NIGHT TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KIM CHANG WITH THE
AUTO CLUB OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES- I JUST WANT
TO ADD THAT THAT CERTAINLY WE
JUST WANT TO GIVE THE COURT THE
DISCRETION TO HAVE THIS- THIS
OPTION- TO- TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. YES THERE SHOULD BE
NOTICED- THERE SHOULD. AM I MY
OPINION AND I THINK THAT IF YOU
HEAR FROM THE TESTIMONY THE
FACT THAT THE EXHIBITION OF
SPEED IS TREATED DIFFERENTLY
FROM A SPEED CONTEST- THEY
SHOULD BE TREATED THE SAME AND
THAT'S ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR IS
FOR THE COURT. TO HAVE THE
EXACT SAME- PUNISHMENTS AND-
AND PENALTIES AS A SPEECH
CONTEST AND THAT'S AND SO
STRICTLY ASPEN HIGH ABOVE.
THANK YOU ARE THEIR INCOME. OR
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. YEAH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
RESET UP THE ACLU'S OPPOSITION-
I HAD HEARD YOU WERE GOING TO
WORK WITH THEM TO GET THEM OFF
OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT. YES
IT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE ACLU AND THE OPPOSITION TO
REMOVE THEIR- THEIR OPPOSITION
WE CERTAINLY ARE OPEN TO
EXEMPTIONS I THINK THAT OUR
BILL HAS AN EXEMPTION TO ALLOW
AN INDIVIDUAL TO. HAVE THEIR
LICENSE TO OUGHT TO GO TO WORK-
WE WILL BE OPEN TO IT TO ADDING
AN EDUCATION EXEMPTION AS WELL
BUT- AND THOSE THINGS WE CAN
CERTAINLY WORK OUT. AND DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT WITH THAT TAKING
THOSE MOMENTS YOU'LL GET THEM
OFF OPPOSITION BUT IF THAT IF
AS HAS MENTIONED- BY THE ACLU
THAT IS OUR CONCERN THAT IT'S
TOO RESTRICTIVE AND SO WE WOULD
BE WE WOULD HOPEFULLY BE OPEN
TO WORKING WITH. YOU AND IF
THEY ARE OPEN TO THOSE TWO
EGGS- TO- EXEMPTIONS WHICH WERE
OPEN TO AS WELL- WE'RE HAPPY.
TO SEE IF THEY WOULD REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION. DEMAND FOR.
OPPOSITE WOULD HAVE. YEAH IT
I'M- I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE BUT A- YOU WOULD COULD
WOULD YOU MIGHT ADDRESS THAT
STEVE THAT. WOULD THAT WOULD
PLAY OFF OPPOSITION IF YOU TO
TAKE MOMENTS- SO. IT'S A LITTLE
HARD TO SAY IN PORTLAND
WITHOUT- IN LANGUAGE I THINK
WHAT WOULD BRING UP A
COMPETITION. IS TO EXTEND THE
EXEMPTION THAT CAN BE ALLOWED.
UNDER THE LAW THAT CURRENTLY.
ISN'T QUITE OR- BENEFITS SPEED
RACING- PROVISION- REGARDING.
TRAVEL TO AND FROM WORK- TO.
ALLOW FOR TRAVEL TO AND FROM
SCHOOL BUT ALSO TO- PUT IN
LANGUAGE TO. REQUIRE THE JUDGE
IN CONSIDERING WHETHER TO
SUSPEND SOMEONE'S LIFE AND-
OTHER IMPACT ON THE FAMILY
THINGS LIKE- BEING ABLE TO TAKE
OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS TO WORK
OR- FAMILY MEMBERS. TO MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS AND I BELIEVE
THERE ARE SOME CODE SECTION BUT
THE PROVIDE A MODEL PROJECT-
JUST GIVING THOSE. FACTORS THE
JUDGE TO CONSIDER. IN MAKING
THE TO. SO ALL I WOULD JUST SAY
TO THE- THAT'S MY COLLEAGUES
COURT HOLDS THE THAT THAT THE-
TO. THIS INDIVIDUAL PLANS OR TO
A DRIVER TO BE A LAW TO TRY TO
AND FROM WORK AND WE WOULD ADD
INS AS WELL HAVE TO WORK THE
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO. CONCERNS
THAT WE WANT TO CODIFY. THAT
DISCUSSIONS OF THE COURT IN
SOME WAY BUT THE COURT HAS THE
DISCRETION BUT IF WE WANTED. TO
CODIFY THAT IN IN THE LAW- INTO
THIS BILL. WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION. I I'LL JUST
ADD AYE AYE DO HOPE THAT YOU
WERE THE OPPOSITION. TO GET
THEM OFF AND WITH THAT ALL OF A
TO MOVE THE BILL. TODAY UNDER
THAT HOPE THAT YOU DO THAT WITH
THE CITY. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WELL I
WANT TO THANK- OF VICE CHAIR
FONG FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL WE HE DID TAKE. THE
COMMITTEES SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
WHICH MAKE SURE THAT THE
LICENSE SUSPENSION SUSPENSION
IS AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
COURT. AT THE COURT HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO PERMITTED DRIVER
TO USE THE CAR. TO AND FROM
WORK INSTEAD OF A FULL LICENSE
SUSPENSION AND- SOUNDS LIKE
HE'S OPEN TO. GIVING THE JUDGE
A MOTHER DISCRETION IN IN CASE-
AND ONCE AGAIN JUST TO
REITERATE THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE A NEW COME CRIME IT JUST
BRINGS THIS TYPE OF SPEED-
EXHIBITION IN LINE WITH STREET
RACING AND- WE- FREQUENTLY SEE
THIS YOU KNOW PARTICULARLY IN.
LOS ANGELES OF THESE KINDS OF
EXHIBITIONS OF SPEED AND BY THE
WAY. THIS IS NOT USED IN JUST A
SIMPLE SPEEDING CASE THESE ARE
PEOPLE THAT ARE- IT RACING CARS
OFTEN FOR FROM. MONEY
EXHIBITION SIDESHOWS BUT ON
PUBLIC STREETS PUTTING THE
PUBLIC IN GREAT HARM. AND THESE
ARE NOT CARS A LOT OF TIMES
THAT ARE BEING USED FOR WORK
THESE ARE TRICKED OUT VEHICLES
THAT GO TWO HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES AN HOUR THAT HAVE
FIVE POINT RACING HARNESSES-
THAT ARE. THAT ARE TRICKED OUT.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY. C. H. P. RESPOND OVER
TO FIVE TO. CALLS FOR SPEED
CONTESTS AND MOTOR VEHICLE
EXHIBITIONS OF SPEED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. WHICH IS
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED MORE THAN
THE YEAR BEFORE. SPEEDING IS
RESPONSIBLE 431% OF TRAFFIC
FATALITIES. WELL I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE IS HE'LL USE
CONCERNS AND I APPLAUD THEM FOR
SPEAKING UP FOR PEOPLE. DRIVING
IS NOT A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT IT'S
A PRIVILEGE AND ONE THAT SHOULD
NOT COME AT THE EXPENSE. OF
INNOCENT BYSTANDERS AND PEOPLE
WHO- EXHIBIT THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR. REALLY NEED TO. HAVE
THE CAR TAKEN AWAY FOR A WHILE
QUITE HONESTLY. UNTIL THEY
LEARN TO. HAVE SOME
CONSIDERATION FOR OTHER PEOPLE
THAT ARE ON THE ROAD AND
CERTAINLY. SOMEBODY LIKE. OUR
WITNESSES SON. DESERVES HIS
RIGHTS TO BE A BYSTANDER AND TO
BE A PEDESTRIAN RESPECTED AS
WELL. SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD. I LOOK FOR
TO VOTING FOR TODAY AND WITH
THAT CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG I BERMAN.
BERMAN I MATHIS MATHIS AYE DALY
DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I'D
GIPSON. KALRA. NUMBER LI PLAY
NOW MEDINA. MEDINA I IN THIS
AREA. NAZARIAN I WENT.
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I WARD.
WARD I WICKS WIXII. CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN ONE PARTICULAR
BILLS OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN UP NEXT WE HAVE AB ONE
TWENTY TWO. WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE THINK MADAM CHAIR AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STUFF FOR THE YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB ONE TWENTY TWO
WOULD MAKE INTERSECTIONS SAFER
FOR BICYCLISTS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS BY ALLOWING
BICYCLISTS TO TREAT STOP SIGNS
AS YIELD SIGNS WHEN APPROACHING
AN INTERSECTION. WELL THIS MAY
SEEM COUNTERINTUITIVE YIELDING
ALREADY THE LAW IT PROVIDES A
CLEAR LEGAL DEFINITION AN
EXPECTATION FOR THOSE REQUIRED
TO YIELD A FOUR WAY
INTERSECTIONS UNDER EXISTING YO
BUT DON'T LAW THE DRIVER OF ANY
VEHICLE INCLUDING EVIL BIKES
APPROACHING AN INTERSECTION
WITH THE YIELD RIGHT OF WAY
SIGN. MUST YIELD TO ANY
VEHICLES THAT HAVE ENTERED THAT
INTERSECTION AB ONE TWENTY TWO
USES OF COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF
A YIELD SIGN TO ALLOW
BICYCLISTS APPROACHING THE
INTERSECTION TO SLOW DOWN AND
YIELD TO ANY CARS AND
PEDESTRIANS. ALREADY IN THE
INTERSECTION IF IT IS SAFE TO
DO SO THE BIKERS COULD CONTINUE
THROUGH THE INTERSECTION.
WITHOUT MAKING A COMPLETE STOP.
WELL SUMMER STUDY ON BY THREE
INDICATES THE PRICE. OFTEN
YOU'LL OF AND- ALREADY THIS
BILL IT'S IMPORTANT TO CREATE A
COMMON EXPECTATION OF THIS
BEHAVIOR THUS FURTHER IMPROVING
THE FLOW OF TRAFFIC AND
EVERYONE'S SAFETY AT
INTERSECTIONS. DELAWARE ADOPTED
THE STUFF WITH THE OLD OFFER
PRICE WITH THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. THE DELAWARE STATE
POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS RECENTLY
REPORTED A 23% REDUCTION IN
ACCIDENTS INVOLVING BCYCLISTS
AT INTERSECTIONS DURING THEIR
FIRST THIRTY MONTHS DUE TO
HAVING A CLEAR EXPECTATION. ON
WHAT TO DO WHEN APPROACHING AN
INTERSECTION. IN FACT OF THE
SEVERAL THINGS THAT ARE ALREADY
PASSED THE STOP AS YOU'LL LAWS
NONE HAVE DISCOVERED DISCOVERED
ANYTHING OTHER THAN
IMPROVEMENTS. IN INTERSECTION
SAFETY. WHETHER CALIFORNIANS
RIDE FOR RECREATION AS PART OF
A SUSTAINABLE LIFESTYLE OR
BECAUSE THAT THEY'RE ONLY
TRANSPORTATION OPTION. AB ONE
TWENTY TWO INSURERS THE
BICYCLIST DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS ARE SAFE A FOUR WAY
INTERSECTION. ALL ROADS NEED TO
BE SAFE FOR ALL ROAD USERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
I HAVE HERE TODAY WITH ME IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL DAVE SNYDER
WITH CAL BY THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. AND PHIL COLEMAN. RETIRED
CHIEF OF POLICE FROM DAVIS.
THANK YOU FIRST PLEASE TO ME.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT COMMITTEE
CHAIRED COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU SHARE FRIEDMAN FOR
YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT CONNECTING
TRANSPORTATION TO COMMUNITIES
WE ARE AT THE CALIFORNIA
BICYCLE COALITION. ARE ABOUT
COMMUNITIES I SHOULD USE MYSELF
DAVE SNYDER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION. I WE ARE ABOUT
COMMUNITIES MORE THAN THE
MACHINE OF THE BICYCLE WE'RE
ABOUT MAKING AN EQUITABLE
INCLUSIVE PROSPEROUS IN WE KNOW
THAT- ENABLING ALL PEOPLE TO
ENJOY THE HEALTH BENEFITS. AND
THE SHEER JOY OF BICYCLING IS A
POWERFUL WAY TO MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES BETTER. WE DO A LOT
OF WORK TO HELP FOLKS. HAVE
DIGNITY AND SAFETY. AND BE
RESPONSIBLE MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMUNITY WHEN THEY RIDE BY
THIS BILL DOES THAT WHICH IS
WHY WE'VE SPONSORED AND
SUPPORTED STRONGLY. AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT CRASHES GO UP
WHEN THIS BILL IS IMPLEMENTED
AND EVIDENCE THAT THEY MIGHT GO
DOWN AT INTERSECTIONS. THERE'S
ANOTHER SAFETY REASON AND I
WANT TO MENTION. THAT OUR
MEMBERS. PROBABLY SOME OF THEM
HAVE A HARD TIME WITH ME
MENTIONING BUT I THINK IT'S
WORTH POINTING OUT AND THAT IS.
THAT- PEOPLE DON'T LIKE TO
RIDE- BUSY ARTERIALS WITH FAST
TRAFFIC LET'S BE REAL WE HAVE A
RIGHT TO RIDE ON THOSE. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PROTECT THAT
RIGHT BUT NOBODY REALLY LIKES
TO BLOCK TRAFFIC BY TAKING THE
LANE ON A FAST BUSY ARTERIALS.
WHICH IS OFTEN THE ONLY WAY TO
RIDE SAFELY ON STREETS LIKE
THAT. IF WE REALLY WANT TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO RIDE BIKES
SAFELY INCLUDING PEOPLE WHO
DON'T WANT TO BE THE AGGRESSIVE
BICYCLIST. WE REALLY HAVE TO.
MAKE IT SAFE AND EASY FOR THEM
TO TAKE THE SIDE STREETS. THIS
BILL WON'T CHANGE ANYTHING FOR
MOTORISTS OR PEDESTRIANS-
PEOPLE ON BIKES WILL STILL HAVE
TO YIELD TO TRAFFIC AT
INTERSECTIONS. AND STOP IF
NECESSARY JUST LIKE THEY
CURRENTLY DO- IT WILL CHANGE
THINGS FOR PEOPLE O BIKES ARE
NOT ONLY ABOUT TRAFFIC SAFETY
BUT ALSO ABOUT PERSONAL SAFETY.
AT IN LOTS OF NEIGHBORHOODS
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE A WOMAN
YOU DON'T WANT TO STOP AND LOSE
YOUR MOMENTUM. MISTER SNYDER
YOUR TIME IS UP IF YOU CAN JUST
FINISH UP. OKAY SURE I'M SORRY-
OKAY. YEAH ANYWAY- WE THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR TRAFFIC
SAFETY FOR ABOUT PERSONAL
SAFETY AND IT WILL HELP
INTERSECTIONS BE MORE
PREDICTABLE BECAUSE PEOPLE WILL
OBEY THE RULE THAT MAKES SENSE
AT AND WE URGE YOU TO PASS IT
AND AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. TWO MINUTES. IF
THE NET NEXT WITNESS ON PHONE.
OKAY. CAN SOMEONE FIND THE
WITNESS AND WERE FOREVER THEY
MAYBE CYBERSPACE TELEPHONE LAND.
THE HEARING ROOM SOMEWHERE.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE ON THE
PHONE PLEASE PRESS STAR THEN
ZERO AND WILL PLAY YOUR LINE
OUT.
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
GIVE THE INSTRUCTIONS ONE MORE
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL
MANAGE YOUR ONLINE PLEASE PRESS
STAR ZERO AND WE WILL PLAY
ONLINE THANK YOU. WE'RE
CURRENTLY CHECKING ON TWO LINES
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT OKAY.
YEAH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE PERSONAL CHECKING FOR
HEADLINE.
WE'RE CURRENTLY NOT
SHOWING SHALL COMMENT ON THE
FALL. OKAY WE WILL CONTINUE
WITH OUR HEARING AND IF HE
COMES BACK WE WILL TAKE HIS
TESTIMONY. SO WITH THAT DO WE
HAVE ANY. TESTIMONY HERE IN THE
ROOM ANY PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
THE ROOM. I DO NOT SEE ANY SO I
WOULD ASK FOR THE PHONE LINES
TO BE OPEN FOR TESTIMONY FROM
THE PUBLIC. IF YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THEN AFTER THIS I WILL GO
TO THE SEE IF HE'S THERE AGAIN
I'LL GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE STRIVING HERE JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR FIRST COMMENT. NINE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR
YOU PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY MY
NAME IS DEEPER ALL THE STATE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON BICYCLE
SAFETY FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS- CALIFORNIA. WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL IT'S CONTRARY TO
WHAT WE TEACH OUR YOUNG BUT FOR
WRITERS AND YOU AT THE END BOTH
PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLE RIDING-
ARE WE TEACHING THE FULLY
STOPPED BECAUSE SIGN BECAUSE
THEY NEED TO STOP AND PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT COMING AND
GOING ACROSS THEIR- FIELD
ASIAN- THEY DO NOT HAVE. ANY
EXPERIENCE DRIVING CARS I HAVE
NO IDEA HOW CARS GOING TO REACT
OR HOW LONG IT TAKES FOR CARDED
NOTICE THEM OR TO STOP WE WOULD
REQUEST IF YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WITH THIS BILL IT
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE ANY BICYCLE RIDER
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN IS
NOT ALLOWED TO- IGNORE A STOP
SIGN. SECOND THING IS
CALIFORNIA HAS THE THIRD
LARGEST- NUMBER OF GREAT A
NUMBER OF BICYCLE FACILITIES-
VERSUS CAR VERSUS A BICYCLE
THAT PRIMARILY A HEAD INJURY
ISSUE- IN CALIFORNIA THE VAST
MAJORITY OF ADULTS DO NOT WEAR
HELMETS IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE
THEM BY THE THROUGH
INTERSECTIONS- IN TRYING TO
GAUGE THEIR ABILITY TO BEA
CAR- THERE WILL BE MORE-
BICYCLE VERSUS- CAR COLLISIONS.
STEP DOWN TO AVOID SEVERE HEAD
INJURIES EVERY ADULT AND SHOULD
BE REQUIRED JUST LIKE WE DO
WITH MOTORCYCLE COME WHAT THE
OF MOTORCYCLES TO WEAR HELMETS-
THOSE ISSUES NEED TO BE
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED YEP WE'RE
GONNA MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE BILL
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. THE BILL-
WE- GO FORWARD WE HAVE STEP
BACK IN YEAH. TO IS A
PROTECTION YOURSELF. YEAH YOU
CAN FINISH UP PLEASE OKAY BUT-
BUT THAT WE'RE WILLING TO DO
WITH THE AUTHOR ON ON ON- OUR
CHANGES TO THE BILL BUT- THIS
IS NOT GOOD FOR. SIX ALL. HEY I
HAVE I DO WHO ARE DIDN'T HAVE
LIST THAT YOU WERE OUT READY
OFFICE. SO IF YOU TO TAKE
ANOTHER HALF AMID THAT'S FINE.
YEAH WE- SO THE IS THE CALPERS
COALITION FOR CHILDREN SO
HEALTH THE STATE WIDE.
COALITION WORKS ON CRAPPIE
SAFETY- DROWNING. HE TALKED.
POISONING YOUR DAUGHTER WE'VE
BEEN DOING FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS- CALIFORNIA. THIS WAS
COMPLETELY CONTRARY TO THE
DIRECTION. WE'VE BEEN GOING TO
GET TROUT. DOWN IN SO TO GET
BETTER- BETTER BICYCLE RIDING
TRAFFIC- AUG DOG PROCEDURES OF
BEHAVIORS- ESPECIALLY FOR KIDS-
I JUST WANT TO REPEAT THAT. IF
YOU WANT TO HELP TO MAKE SURE
IT HAPPENS. HELLO. I'M NOT SURE
IF I'M STILL UNDER LOCK. THE R.
R. WERE YOU FINISHED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY. YEAH WE'LL WILL-
JUST BY BOARD APPROPRIATIONS
THE FLOOR AND OVER IN THE
CENTER OF THIS BILL CONTINUES
TO MOVE BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
MEET WITH THE AUTHOR TO TALK
ABOUT HOW YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
THIS KIND OF LONG PLACE HOW IT
NEEDS TO AVOID DRAGGING KIDS
INTO TRYING TO MAKE A DECISION
WHETHER TO- DRIVE THROUGH A
STOP SIGN OR I'D BE HERE TO THE
SHOP AND THEY NEED TO STOP
EVERY TIME. AND THIS COVERS ALL
AGES IT'S NOT A JOB AT LEAST AN
AGE DEMARCATION OKAY- AND ALSO
IT NEEDS TO REQUIRE ALL ADULTS
TO WEAR HELMETS IF THEY'RE
GONNA PUT THEMSELVES AT RISK.
AND TAXPAYERS PAYING FOR THEIR
HEAD INJURY WHICH IS ONE HAVE
INSURANCE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE INITIAL HOSPITAL COSTS-
THE REASON WE HAVE HELMETS ON
MOTORCYCLE RIDERS IS BECAUSE OF
THE COSTA RICA PANAMA. AND
CAUSING A LOT OF THE TALENTS
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. AND I BELIEVE
WE HAVE TRIPLE A ALSO LISTED AS
SPEAKING OPERATOR CAN YOU. SEE
IF TRIPLE A IS AVAILABLE. THANK
YOU ARE KERN ALSO HAVE SHOWN
CALL MINUTE DIALED WE HAVE
MEANT- JOHN. SALTZMAN I'M NOT
SURE WHO THE WITNESS WITH THE
BUT WE DO HAVE TO OUR LINE OKAY
WHOEVER THIS. WAY THEY SHOULD
BE REPRESENTING TRIPLE A. I'M
SORRY THAT YOU THAT WAS THE
OTHER WITNESS WHO IS THE
SUPPORT WITNESS YOU SAID YOU
HAVE ON THE LINE. YES SO DID
JUST IRANIANS ON. OKAY WHY
DON'T WE BRING HIM AND THEN IF
YOU CAN TRY TO TRACK DOWN
TRIPLE A- WHO IS ALSO SUPPOSED
TO BE TO- TESTIFIED THAT WOULD
BE TERRIFIC. OKAY SIR. SHOW
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER COLEMAN
CAN YOU HEAR US YEAH OKAY
YOU'RE ON YOUR MINUTES PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. I'M SORRY
FOR THIS I CAN'T EXPLAIN- MY
NAME IS PHIL COLEMAN- MADAM
CHAIR AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AND I COME TO YOU IN TWO
CAPACITIES I'VE- BRITAIN'S
STREETS AND ROADS AS A BICYCLE
US IN CALIFORNIA AND SEVENTEEN
OTHER STATES FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL DECADES. I'VE ALSO HAD
PAST EXPERIENCES A MUNICIPAL
POLICE OFFICER IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR THE SAME SEVERAL DECADES
AND MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXPERIENCE INCLUDES ROLES AS A
TRAFFIC ENFORCER SUPERVISOR.
AND ADMINISTRATOR OF TRAFFIC
ENFORCEMENT POLICY WHILE
SERVING AS A CITY POLICE CHIEF.
NOW THERE ARE OTHERS WHO WILL
SPEAK TO. THIS BILL FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A BICYCLIST BUT
I'LL LIMIT MY REMARKS. TO THAT
OF A TRAFFIC ENFORCER. OF THE
VEHICLE AND SPECIFICALLY STOP
SIGN ENFORCEMENT. AS IT APPLIES
TO CALIFORNIA BY. SIX DIRECTING
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE AB ONE
TWENTY TWO FACTS HE- FOR THIS
BILL AND THE SUBSECTION TITLED
BACKGROUND. THAT SUMMATION IS
ACTOR. MANY OR MOST BICYCLIST
TRY TO KEEP AT LEAST SOME
MOMENTOUS. RATHER THAN COME TO
A TOTAL STUFF SO THAT THEY CAN
CLEAR THE DANGER CENTER SECTION
MORE QUICKLY. LET'S CALL THIS
THE EXISTING REALITY FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A BICYCLIST. NOW
PATROL AND TRAFFIC ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS HAVE ALMOST UNLIMITED
DISCRETION. WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT OF VEHICLE CODE
VIOLATIONS. OF THE MANY THAT
THEY SEE EVERY DAY MOST ARE
IGNORED. SOME OTHERS I DEALT
WITH WAS STOP AND WARM. AND
FEWER STILL FALL UNDER THE
FINAL OPTION TO ENFORCE THE
VIOLATION BY CITATION OR ARREST
THESE MEN AND WOMEN IN POLICE
UNIFORM FOR THE SELECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT COUNTLESS TIMES
EVERY WORK DAY. WHAT IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO THIS
DISCUSSION. WHEN IT COMES TO A
STOP SIGN ENFORCEMENT
CALIFORNIA STREET COPS HAVE
THAT SAME EXISTING REALITY AB
TWO BICYCLISTS APPROACHING A
STOP SIGN. THANK YOU CAN FINISH
UP EARLY SIR. YOUR TEAM IS THAT
BICYCLISTS NOT STRICTLY OBEYING
STOP SIGNS. RATHER TREAT THEM
AS BEING ACCEPTABLE AS YIELD
SIGNS. AND IS EMBRACED BY THE
VAST MAJORITY OF UNIFORMED
POLICE OFFICERS. SO THEY SHARE
THE SAME. CURRENT REALITY IN
CLOSING I ASKED YOU TO SUPPORT
THE PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE TWENTY TWO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR CAN YOU SEE OF
OUR OTHER WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
TRIPLE A IS AVAILABLE. YOUR
ONLINE TO TESTIFY FOR TRIPLE A
AS A WITNESS PLEASE PRESS STAR
AND ONE ZERO AND WE CAN PULL
YOUR LINE. WE ALSO HAVE
JONATHON FELDMAN ON THE LINE.
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE Q. THIS
PERSON UP.
BLIND FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS AMANDA CALDERON WITH
TRIPLE A THE AUTO CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ANY POSITION OF
OPPOSING AMENDED TO FOUR EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THAT ON
OUR AMENDMENTS FOR THE- BELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH THAT OPERATOR CAN YOU SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE FOR ONE MINUTE
TESTIMONY. CALLER ONE MINUTE
ONLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. LINE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BORDERLINE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS JAMES OF OUR
DINNER WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION BY THING
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. DO
YOU HAVE ONE MORE LIGHT INTO
ARE JUST BE ONE MOMENT. OVER
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR ANESTHESIA
CULTURE QUICK CALIFORNIA VISORS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I DO HAVE ONE MORE THAT
JUST QUEUED UP. AND WE'RE
TRYING TO FORTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI JULIE RANDOLPH WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
WITHOUT WILL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS MR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
ARE YOU CONTEMPLATING- ANY OF
THE ISSUES BROUGHT UP BY THE
AUTO CLUB REGARDING. THE
RELATIVE SPEED OF E. BIKES FOR
THE MAXIMUM SPEED IS TWENTY
EIGHT MILES AN HOUR FOR AN E.
BIKE. MANY RESIDENTIAL STREETS
AT LOWER SPEED LIMITS THEY'RE
SUGGESTING SOME SUCH TYPE OF A
STUDY- ANY COMMENT ON THAT
ASPECT YEAH SURE- WE WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STUFFING COMMITTEE
STUFF IF YOU LOOK AT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS PUT THEM IN
THE SAME CODE SECTION- AND NOT
ALL E. BIKES GO UP TO TWENTY
MILES AN HOUR. I MIGHT BE BACK
FOR EXAMPLE DOES NOT- SO I
THINK IT RIGHT NOW THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION WAS
TO TREAT KEEP THEM TREATED AS
THE SAME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS Q. MANAGER I JUST WANT TO
SAY I LIKE THE BILL WOULD LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
THANK YOU. FOR ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. WELL I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD I WOULD LIKE TO BE
A- ADDED AS A JOINT AUTHORS. OF
THE BILL- I JUST WANTED TO ADD
THAT DATA FROM DELAWARE SHOWS
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THIS
LAW THAT THE SAME LAW THAT THEY
HAVE IN THEIR STATE. REDUCE
LIKE LISTEN JUST- INJURIES AT
INTERSECTIONS BY TWENTY TWO
PERCENT- AND I CAN TELL YOU IS
SOMEBODY WHO DOES RIDE
FREQUENTLY TO THE CAPITAL. THAT
GOING TO COMING TO A COMPLETE
STOP. IS NOT ALWAYS DONE BY ALL
CYCLISTS AND IT'S TAKES A LOT
OF ENERGY TO GO FROM A STOP TO
A START- SO IT ALSO IS
SOMETHING THAT IS A BIT OF A
BARRIER FOR PEOPLE- TO RIDE-
THIS IS ALSO A PILOT. WITH AN
END DATE WITH THE STUDY TO LOOK
AT THE EFFECTS WHICH SHOULD
MAKE SOME OF US WHO MAYBE WERE
A LITTLE BIT MORE NERVOUS.
ABOUT MOVING FORWARD GIVE US
SOME CONFIDENCE THAT THIS WILL
BE EVALUATED BEFORE THE PROGRAM
IS CONTINUED- WITH THAT. CAN WE
OPEN THE ROLE PLEASE. AT THE-
THE- IS TO DO PASSED AS AMENDED.
WE'LL CALL PLEASE. FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG HE DIDN'T.
BONTA I THOUGHT I'M SORRY I
THOUGHT WE HAD A MOTION DID WE
NOT HAVE A MOTION OR SECOND. WE
HAVE A MOTION AND WE HAVE A
SECOND. I'M SORRY BUT I THOUGHT
I HAD HEARD OF. LET'S START
OVER WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FONG.
FONG I BERMAN OH NO SORRY I
APOLOGIZE BERMAN. BERMAN I
MATHIS. MATHIS NO DALY DALY AYE
DAVIES DAVIES NOW GIPSON. KALRA.
KALRA I LATE. MEDINA MEDINA AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I WENT. UNL
O'DONNELL. O'DONNELL I WARD.
LORD I WICKS WICKS I. WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT AND LAST BILL OF THE
DAYS AB TWO TWENTY.
MR VOEPEL
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY I AM A
CHAIR VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO START OFF
WITH THANK YOU THE CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS BILL. I'M NOT A
CAR PERSON. SO AB TWO TWENTY
ASSEMBLY MOVING THE DATE OF
SMALL EXEMPTION FOR COLLECTOR
CARS FROM CARS MANUFACTURED
BEFORE. NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THAT'S
JUST ADVANCE UNIT SEVEN YEARS
THERE HAS BEEN SOME CONFUSION
REGARDING THIS BILL AS TO WHO
DOES THIS ACTUALLY AFFECT. AB
TWO TWENTIES MAIN FOCUS IS TO
EXEMPT COLLECTOR CARS FROM THE
SMALL CHECK THAT HAVE BEEN
MANUFACTURED BEFORE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE. WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT CLUNKERS WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT- ANYTHING OTHER
THAN HIGHLY VALUABLE COLLECTOR
CARS AB TWO TWENTY WAS NOT
INTENDED TO BE A BLANKET
EXEMPTION FOR ALL CARS
MANUFACTURED BEFORE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE AND THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY IN THE WORKS FOR
BEING AMENDED TO REFLECT THAT.
IF THIS BILL IS THE PASSED THIS
COMMITTEE I AM WILLING TO
ACCEPT ANY OTHER AMENDMENTS
GOING FORWARD. ESPECIALLY
APPROPRIATIONS. BEFORE NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT VEHICLES
MANUFACTURED PRIOR TO THE
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX MODEL YEAR
WERE EXEMPT FROM THE SMALL
CHECK PROGRAM. SB FORTY TWO.
SENATOR CAPS. IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN EXTENDED THE
EXEMPTION TO ALL VEHICLES
MANUFACTURED PRIOR TO THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MODEL
YEAR ESTABLISHING A ROLE IN
EXEMPTION. UNTIL AB. TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY THREE SENATOR OR I'M
SORRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVER IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR REPEALED THE
THIRTY YEAR ROLLING EXEMPTION
AND INSTEAD EXEMPTED VEHICLES
MANUFACTURED PRIOR TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. SO WE USED TO HAVE
A AUTOMATIC RULE LEAN EXEMPTION
FOR THE COLLECTOR CARS THEN
THEY FROZE IT. FOR NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. THIS LEGISLATION
HAS REMAINED UNTOUCHED FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS. SO AT THIS TIME
WITH THE CHAIRS PERMISSION I
WOULD NOW LIKE TO PASS IT ON
THE BILL ADAMS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA CAR CLUBS AND AFTER
THAT I'D SAY A MAN DAY ALLSTATE
INSURANCE BEFORE YOU DO THAT I
DO WANT TO MAKE I WANT TO
CLARIFY SOMETHING IN YOUR
STATEMENT YOU SAID THAT THIS
BILL. IS TO EXEMPT THE
COLLECTOR CARS BUT I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT YOUR BILL EXAMS
ALL CARS BEFORE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE FROM SMOG CHECK NOT JUST
COLLECTOR CARS I'M LOOKING AT
THE BILL TAX AND IT SAYS ALL
CAR IT'S ALL CARS SO I JUST
WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR BECAUSE
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT HERE IF
YOU IF YOU ARE REPRESENTING
THAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT
COLLECTOR CARS IT IS NOT IT
MAKES CAPTURE THEM BUT IT IS
ALL CARS BEFORE NINETY THREE I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT AND NOW
LET'S GO TO YOUR FIRST WITNESS
TWO MINUTES PLEASE. HEY MY
NAME'S BILL ADAMS WITH THE-
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CAR
CLUBS AND COLLECTORS. WE FORMED
A BRIDGE BETWEEN THE AUTOMOTIVE
ENTHUSIAST AND OUR ELECTED
OFFICIALS WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
ALMOST FIFTY YEARS- THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US AND- PUSHING THIS
HEARING- WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- IT AS WE UNDERSTAND
IT THIS BILL WOULD- EXEMPTS
COLLECTOR CARS- AND WE DO
UNDERSTAND THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION AND WE HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH THIS.
CONFUSION WHETHER IT'S TO AMEND
IT FURTHER BUT- WE ARE VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF A AT. A BILL
EXEMPTING COLLECTOR CARS-
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
OF THE BILL AND PASSED BILLS OF
A SIMILAR NATURE IT IS PAINTED
A BROAD BRUSH OF ALL VEHICLES
AND THE- SPECIFICALLY- ANYTHING
IN EIGHT YEARS BUT WE WERE.
ANYTHING THAT CALLED AS A
COLLECTOR CAR WOULD BE VERY
SPECIFIC AND COULD NOT SHOULD
NOT BE PAINTED WITH SUCH A
BROAD BRUSH- ALSO. LIST WOULD
ALSO ALLOW A LOT OF OTHER
YOUNGER ENTHUSIASTS TO BRING
INTO- CAR SHOWS ARE CLUBS- A
CROSS CAL. AND WEEKEND THERE'S
A CAR SHOWS. AND GENERALLY WAS
CAUTIOUSLY SUPPORTING SORT OF
LOCAL. EVENTS A CHILD WITH THE-
AND AILMENTS- IN SOME CASES
SOME OF THEM HAD EVEN SUPPORTED
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION THE
SIERRA CLUB- WHICH IS
INTERESTING BUT- THIS IS- THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW YOUNGER
ENTHUSIASTS TO CONTINUE TO
PERPETUATE THEIR HOBBY WHICH
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
CLARIFIED IN MANY MANY CASES
THAT IT IT HAS A- LARGE
INTEREST IN. FURTHERING CAR
COLLECTING AND THE CAR HOBBY
WHICH IS- VERY ENDEMIC TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF YOU CAN
FINISH UP YOUR COMMENTS PLEASE
OR AT THE TWO MINUTE MARK. OKAY
AND AGAIN THE A TRIPLE C. HAS
BEEN REPRESENTING COLLECTOR CAR
AND AUTOMOTIVE ENTHUSIAST SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO- AND WE
ARE DEFINITELY IN FAVOR OF
EXEMPTING COLLECTOR CARS. AND
THE YEARS- MENTIONED OKAY THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE ISAIAH MANY
FROM FARMERS INSURANCE I
BELIEVE. BY KATHLEEN ONE TWO
I'M HERE OKAY YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU
AND I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT A TWO
MINUTE DRIVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION TO GO OVER- WHILE I
AM APPOINTED THE FARMERS
INSURANCE WE DON'T WRITE MOST
POLICIES OF WHAT THE COLLECTOR
CAR POLICIES WE ACTUALLY DON'T
INSURE THROUGH THEM THERE ARE.
ABOUT FOUR OR FIVE SPECIFICALLY
COLLECTOR CAR INSURANCE
COMPANIES THAT WE USED TO WRITE
THESE VEHICLES BECAUSE JUST TO
CLARIFY. THE DEMOGRAPHIC THAT-
I REPRESENT IS TRUMP COLLECTOR
CARS IN OUTLOOK THROUGH THE
REQUIREMENTS AND WHAT IT TAKES
TO RUN- INSURE A COLLECTOR CAR
VEHICLE. NOW WHEN I GET A NEW
APPLE CAN'T. BEFORE I EVEN FILL
OUT THE APPLICATION THERE'S A
FEW QUESTIONS THAT I USED TO
BACK WHETHER OR NOT. THEY WOULD
BE- A RIGHT FIT FOR SUBMISSION
TO UNDERWRITING- THE FIRST
REQUIREMENT IS GOING TO BE. IF
THEY HAVE A SECOND THEY HAVE A
PRIMARY DAILY USE CAR SO THE
COLLECTOR VEHICLE CAN'T BE USED
ON A DAILY BASIS. AND
UNDERWRITING IS VERY STRICT
ABOUT THIS- YOU CAN'T BORROW
YOUR WIFE'S CAR SOMEBODY ELSE'S
CAR THAT YOU YOU LIVE WITH
BECAUSE- THEY ACTUALLY REQUIRE
THE VEHICLE IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER FOR. YOUR DAILY KERR AND
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HOUSEHOLD
THAT YOU LIVE WITH- SO WOULD
THEY WE NEED TO PROVIDE
DOCUMENTATION THAT EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THE HOUSE AND THE CAR.
BEFORE. YOUR COLLECTOR CAR CAN
APPLY- ONE OF THE NEXT
REQUIREMENT IS THE MILEAGE
RESTRICTION. MOST OF THE
COLLECTOR CAR COMPANIES ONLY
ALLOW FOR A FEW THOUSAND MILES-
THEY'RE THE MOST CONSERVATIVE
IN THE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED.
AND A COMPANY THAT ARE RIGHT
THE MOST WITH HIS- UPWARDS OF
THREE THOUSAND MILES WHICH IS
VERY LIMITING AND WITHIN THEIR
HERDS DRASTICALLY- ONE OF THE-
OTHER REQUIREMENTS. THAT
DIFFICULT TO MEET HIS. TRUE
COLLECTOR CARS MUST BE PARKED
IN THIS IS A REQUIREMENT INSIDE
OF IT ENCLOSED GARAGE WITH THE
PORTAL CRUISER I'M GONNA STOP.
STAR OF THE SUBJECT YOUR TIME
IS UP AND I. WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
REFER TO COLLECTOR CARS THE
BILL IS REFERRING TO ALL CARS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL. I HAD-
HAD SUGGESTED SHOULD DEVELOP
SHOULD THE AND WE DON'T SUPPORT
ALL CARS. MANUFACTURED PRIOR TO
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE ONCE
AGAIN OUR OUR DEMOGRAPHIC IS
TRUE COLLECTOR CARS AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD REQUEST
THE BILL BE AMENDED IF IT WORKS
TO BE VOTED FOR WORK OKAY
THAT'S HELPFUL THANK YOU AND
MAYBE HE WILL CONSIDER THAT BUT
THAT IS NOT THE BILL THAT IS
BEFORE US- WE NOW WILL MOVE TO
THE OPPOSITION- WE HAVE- WILL
BEAR. I BELIEVE FIRST TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. AT ACTUALLY
MANTIA BRANDON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I
WAS GONNA. GO FIRST IF YOU
DON'T MIND THAT'S FINE TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SPENDING
TELECOM HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM ALL
THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
IN OPPOSITION AT TEN TWENTY.
WHICH EXEMPTS ALL CARS WITH
MODEL YEAR NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND EARLIER FROM SMOG CHECK.
AUTOMOTIVE EMISSIONS ACCOUNT
FOR OVER 50% OF SMOG FORMING
POLLUTANTS IN CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THE SMOG CHECK PROGRAM
BECAUSE IT'S AN EQUITABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO CUT AIR
POLLUTION WITHOUT REGULAR
INSPECTIONS ARE SMOG CHECK
VEHICLE EMISSIONS CONTROL
SYSTEMS INTEGRATED OVER TIME-
CAN BE CAPITALIST DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING AIR POLLUTION. THE
PROGRAMS ESSENTIAL FOR CLEAN
AND PUBLIC HEALTH AND IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
OLDER VEHICLES SUCH AS THOSE
THIS BILL WOULD EXACT. COUNT A
FAILURE RATE OF OVER TWENTY TWO
PERCENT. UNDER THE PROGRAM FOR
OLDER VEHICLES ARE NOT HELD TO
THE SAME STANDARDS AS NEWER
VEHICLES IN FACT I'M NOT EVEN
HELD TO THE EMISSION STANDARDS
THEY ACHIEVED WHEN THEY WERE
NEW. AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
PROGRAM TAKES INTO
CONSIDERATION FACTORS SUCH AS
THE AGE MAKE AND MODEL OF THE
VEHICLE AND ALLOWS FOR THE
EXPECTED DETERIORATION OF THE
VEHICLES EMISSIONS CONTROLS
OVER TIME. HELLO RESOURCES
BOARD DATA SHOWS THAT KNOCKS
EMISSIONS FOR NINETEEN EIGHTY
TWO PASSENGER CAR WHICH WOULD
BE NEARLY EXEMPT UNDER THE BILL
IS APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY FOUR
TIMES THE RUNNING EXACERBATE.
OF THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN MODEL
YEAR PASSENGER CAR AND WITHOUT
SMOG CHECK THAT NUMBER GOES UP
TO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
TIMES SO. PLEASE MENTION THAT
OBVIOUS MAINTAIN THEIR
VEHICLES- OR THAT ACTUALLY
LOWER MILEAGE LIMITATIONS AS
MAYBE A FEW THOUSAND MILES A
YEAR- BUT IT AT THREE THOUSAND
MILES A YEAR. EIGHTY FOUR TIMES
MORE KNOCKS EMISSIONS THAT'S
THE EQUIVALENT OF A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PASSENGER CAR DRIVING
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
THOUSAND MILES A YEAR. AND ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE TIMES IT'S
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND MILES SO IF YOU PUSH
THAT OUT. TO NINE THOUSAND
MILES BRINGING YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE EQIPMENT IN OF ONE
POINT ONE. MY TO THINK ABOUT
THIS ANOTHER WAY. FROM THE KNOX
IN. STAND PASSING THIS BILL
WOULD RESULT IN ADDING OF HIS
MILLION. TWENTY SO. CAUSED THE
REST- YOU KNOW I'LL I'LL JUST
READ UP I GET WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT SMALL CHECK ALSO A
CONSUMERS. PROGRAM PROVIDES LOW
INCOME ALONE BECAUSE COMING BY
HIS BILL TO NINE FOR. AND ALSO
INCOME CONDUCTORS FIFTY NINE
YEARS TONIGHT VEHICLE SAY I
RETIRED A KIND OF VEHICLE SO I
JUST WANT THIS TO- EMISSION
CONTROL. AND ON TO THE VIEW.
AND WE THINK THIS OUT AND
EFFECT ON HEALTH AND MAKE IT
CONSIDER HARDER FOR CALIFORNIA
NEEDED TO AIR GOALS ARE EXPECTS
WE REQUEST YOUR. NO VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NO WITNESS
PLEASE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
WILL BEAR IT WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY CAPCO AND DO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS OF A
ROBUST AND COMPREHENSIVE CLEAN
AIR PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION IS
ALSO OPPOSED TO EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY. THE HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
SMOG CHECK PROGRAM IS NECESSARY
TO SUPPORT ATTAINMENT OF HEALTH
PROTECTIVE CLEAN AIR STANDARDS
IN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS CRITICAL
IF CALIFORNIA REMAINS HOME TO
SOME OF THE MOST DIFFICULT AIR
POLLUTION CHALLENGES IN THE
UNITED STATES. MOSTLY DRIVEN BY
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. TRY
PUSHING BECAUSE OF AB ONE
SECOND CHILDREN MAKE HOW THE
WIDE RANGE OF OTHER HEALTH
EFFECTS INCLUDING THE ONSET OF
CHILDHOOD ASTHMA. IMPAIRED LUNG
FUNCTION AND PREMATURE DEATH.
CHILDREN AND TEENAGERS ARE
AMONG THE MOST VULNERABLE AS
ARE THOSE LIVING IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY. MAJOR ROADWAYS. IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE OUR HEALTH
PROTECTIVE AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS CALIFORNIA MUST DO
MORE NOT LESS TO CURB TRAFFIC
POLLUTION. FOR THESE REASONS
AND AGAIN AND THE STATE OF BY
CAPCO WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB TWO
TWENTY. WHICH WOULD ALLOW BROAD
EXEMPTION FOR THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL AND HELP PROTECT ITS
MARKET PROGRAMMING CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING NON OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE FOR THOSE
WISHING TO GIVE ONE MINUTE AND
ONE MINUTE ONLY A TESTIMONY FOR
AGAINST THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT EIGHTEEN Q. RIGHT
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN A
BROAD ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS MAKING A KARATE WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
EVERYTHING STATED BY KEPCO AND
POLITICIZATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR FRIEDMAN
AND MEMBERS IT'S MY NAME'S ALAN
ABBAS WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION SMOG CHECK IS VITAL
TO PROTECTING AND IMPROVING
LOCAL AND REGIONAL AIR QUALITY
25% OF CURRENT CARS UP FROM
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO AND BEFORE
FAILED SMOG CHECK AS IT IS AND
SO GIVEN THESE- THESE VEHICLES.
AN EXEMPTION FROM SMOG CHECK
HAS SUB MY COLLEAGUE BRENDAN TO
IT TO IT MENTIONED WILL
DRASTICALLY INCREASE AIR
POLLUTION FROM THESE VEHICLE
AND CURRENT ONE NOTHING IN SMOG
CHECK PREVENTS CURRENT TVS FOR
MAINTAINING AND SHOWING
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX THROUGH
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO VEHICLES
AND SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR NO VOTE. ON AB TWO TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MEASURE NOT ROBINSON AGAIN
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE MARKET
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH. THE BILL.
THANK YOU ONLINE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR NUMBERS ERIN RODRIGUEZ
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FOUR FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES YES- MY NAME IS LOU
RUBIO I LIVE HERE NEWMAN AND UP.
I AM FOR A B. TWO TWENTY-
OMOKORE CLEAN CLEAN AIR AND THE
THING IS THAT I CAN PUT A SMOG
I MEAN A YEAR. THE FUEL
INJECTION KIT ON MY TRUCK BUT
THE ONLY THING THAT'S STOPPING
ME IS THAT IT'S NOT
MARKLEEVILLE ALTHOUGH I KEEP IN
THE GARAGE IS NOT DRIVEN
EVERYTHING. SO I'M ALL FOR BABY
TO TWENTY AND NOW LOOK AT THEM
ALL FOR CLEAN AIR- I LIKE TO
GET RID OF MY CARBURETOR AND
JUST PUT A SMOG. I MEAN A- FUEL
INJECTION KIT ON THEIR- BY THE
GUY. THIS ONE DOES GONNA TAKE
YOU YEAH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ALREADY. I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY DOING A
RAN OFF WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. WE GO TO
THE COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY QUESTIONS. FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I'M A
BIT CONFUSED HERE HI I'M
READING THE BILL AND IT SAYS
THIS BILL INSTEAD WOULD EXEMPT
FROM THE SMOG CHECK PROGRAM ALL
MOTOR VEHICLES MANUFACTURED.
HIGHER TO NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
MODEL YEAR. BUT WHEN I'M
READING THE COMMITTEES AND
ALICE'S. SAYS EXEMPTS COLLECTOR
MOTOR VEHICLES FROM VISUAL OR
FUNCTIONAL CHECK OF EMISSION
CONTROL DEVICES INCLUDING THE
CATALYTIC CONVERTER AND ON AND
ON IT LIST THREE DIFFERENT
AREAS. SUN A. N. AND OF COURSE
I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID MISS
MADAM CHAIR AND I'M HEARING
WHAT. THE PRESENTER IS SAYING
IS WELL THE AUTHOR IS SAYING.
SO I'M JUST A BIT CONFUSED
WHERE THERE AMENDMENTS
INTRODUCED THAT WE'RE GONNA.
LIMITED TO ONLY COLLECTOR CARS.
NO THE BILL IS WRITTEN HIS
BROAD AND IF AFFECTS ALL CARS
BEFORE NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
COLLECTOR CARS ALREADY HAVE A
PATH FOR SMOG CHECK EXEMPTION
IF THEY MEET CRITERIA OF BEING
COLLECTOR CARS- SO I KNOW THAT
pLIKE TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
ACHIEVE THAT STATUS WHICH WE
ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK ON
BUT THE BILL THAT'S IN FRONT OF
US TODAY IS A BILL WHICH
EXEMPTS ALL CARS. BEFORE NINETY
THREE FROM SMOG CHECK NOT JUST
COLLECTOR CARS THESE WOULD BE
CARDS THAT PEOPLE DO USE AS
THEIR PRIMARY SOURCE OF
TRANSPORTATION YOU KNOW THESE
ARE EXACTLY THE CARS THAT WERE
TRYING TO GET OFF THE ROAD AS
IT IS. WE TRIED TO WORK WITH I
MEAN WE HAVE WE WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS
THE COLLECTOR CAR. CONCERN BUT
THIS BILL- I CAN'T SUPPORT
BECAUSE IT GOES FAR BEYOND THAT
IS THAT YOUR QUESTION. IT IS I
I'M JUST THE DISCREPANCY IS I'M
I'M- TRYING TO FIGURE THIS OUT
THANK. I HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR AND IN
MY CONVERSATIONS WTH HIM ALSO
I'VE LEARNED THAT THIS IS THIS
APPLIES ONLY TO. COLLECTOR
VEHICLES SON TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
DISCREPANCY IS I WOULD LIKE TO
ACTUALLY ASK- MY COMMITTEE
STAFFER TO SPEAK TO WHETHER
THERE WERE ABOUT THE AMENDMENT
PROCESS- MAYBE SHE CAN GIVE US
SOME CLARITY ON THAT. AND SORT
OF WHERE THE DISCREPANCY LAWS
HERE YEAH MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT IS BROADER THAN JUST
ADDRESSING THE COLLECTOR CAR
ISSUE. AND SO WE WOULD LIKE WE
BE OPEN TO LOOKING AT
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD NARROW IT
TO JUST FOCUS ON THE COLLECTOR
CAR ISSUE SO THERE ISN'T A
BROADER SMOG EXEMPTION. DOES
THAT ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION- IT
TO SOME EXTENT AND YES AND NO
BECAUSE THERE'S ALSO THE
QUESTION OF WHAT HAPPENS TODAY
BECAUSE I'M I'M JUST WONDERING
IF THE AUTHOR IS WILLING
COMMITTEE STAFF MANNER AT THIS
POINT TO ALSO MAKE AMENDMENTS
THAT HE CAN COMMIT TO THE CHAIR.
MAY I MAKE A SUGGESTION IF THE
AUTHOR IS WILLING TO WORK WITH
US TO NARROW THIS BILL AND TO
ADDRESS THE COLLECTOR CAR
CONCERNS. MY RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT WE NOT VOTE ON THIS BILL
TODAY AND SAID WE CAN WORK WITH
HIM ON THE BILL ON AMENDMENTS
THAT HE WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE
WOULD THAT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE
TO THE COLLECTOR CAR COMMUNITY
AND HELPFUL TO THEM. WE COULD
TRY TO COME TO SOME AGREEMENT
WITH THAT AND BRING IT BACK IN
A FURTHER HEARING. SO THAT WE
CAN ALL GET ON THE SAME PAGE
AND NONE OF US HERE I DON'T
THINK LISA FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
I. IF THE COLLECTOR CAR
COMMUNITY IS HAVING. AN ISSUE
OR CONCERN. I WOULD LOVE TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THAT AND SEE
HOW WE CAN ADDRESS THAT WITH
THE BILL THAT'S IN FRONT OF US
TODAY GOES FAR BEYOND THAT AND
I CAN NOT SUPPORT THAT BILL SO
IF HE'S WILLING TO NOT TAKE A
VOTE NOW WE CAN. HOLD THE BILL
AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THE BILL AND HOPEFULLY. COME TO
SOME AGREEMENT WITH EVERYBODY.
IF IT LEAKS WE CAN TRY- WE
TAILOR MATHIS- AREA MANAGERS
LIKE TO MOTION THAT THE
COMMITTEE TABLE THE BILL INTEL
OF FURTHER HEARING DATE TO GIVE
THE AUTHOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE YOUR SUGGESTION AND AMEND
THE BILL AND WORK WITH
EVERYBODY TO- IT SEEMS LIKE HE
HAS AN INTENT TO HAVE THIS JUST
FOR THE COLLECTORS- SIDE JUST
MAKING A MOTION FOR HIM TO BE
ABLE TO TABLE BOTH THE BILL. AS
FOR YOUR SUGGESTION- SO WE CAN
BRING IT BACK AT A MATTED WITH
THIS REGISTER MATHIS I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR MOTION I'M
NOT SURE WE NEED A MOTION IF
HE'S AGREEABLE TO JUST NOT
PICKING UP- TODAY IN THE
PHARMACY THE BIG THUMBS UP SO I
DON'T THINK WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
HAVE A VOTE WE WILL JUST NOT
TAKE A TAKE ANY ACTION AT THIS
TIME BUT WE DID HEAR THE
WITNESSES TESTIMONY. AND WE I
THINK WE HEAR THE COLLECTOR CAR
COMMUNITY HAS SOME CONCERNS SO
WE WILL SIT DOWN WITH YOU IN
WITH THEM AND SEE IF WE CAN
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS AND. AND
FIND SOME PATH FORWARD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I
WITH YOU A 100% AND- THE BILL
WAS INTENDED TO SIMPLY. ADDRESS
COLLECTOR CARS. AND IT WENT A
LITTLE BIT SELF THERE'S SO WILL
REDO IT AND MAKE IT GOOD MR
VOEPEL I REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING WITH US
AND I PLEDGE TO WORK WITH YOU
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT. AND WITH THAT. I THINK WE
HAVE TO OPEN THE ROLE FOR. YEAH
I'M GONNA. I'M GONNA CALL ANY
ABSENT OFFICE ANY OFFICE AND
MEMBERS TO COME UP TO THE ROOM
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
VOTE- THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
THOUGH THAT WAT THAT HASN'T
VOTED YET. OKAY SO WHY DON'T WE
GO AHEAD AND START CALLING THE
ROLE NOW SO THAT WE CAN. EXCUSE
THEM. OKAY TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES. GOOD CONVO
OKAY AND IS THERE IN HI. A
RULES RULES YES YES HI WENT HI.
FINAL VOTE. FOURTEEN ZERO. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR NOW
CURRENT VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO
NAZARIAN. CONSENT HI RIGHT WHEN.
YES HI. CONSENT FIFTEEN ZERO. I
SEE YOUR FILE ITEM ONE AB THREE
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN ZERO GIPSON.
WHEN. FINAL VOTE ELEVEN A
TWELVE
. ZERO FINAL VOTE TWELVE
THE ONE. FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE
TWENTY TWO. THREE LAKE. WHEN WE
WROTE IT. AND NOT VOTING. FILE
ITEM ONE AB THREE GIPSON. OUR
OF FINAL VOTE. THIRTEEN ONE.
FILE ITEM THREE AB ONE TWENTY
TWO LEE. START A FILE ITEM
THREE AB ONE TWENTY TWO YES
SORRY I CAN'T LEAVE I FINAL
VOTE.
TEN FOUR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS.